amid all the debate over transgenderism
one of the pro-trans crowd's favorite
talking points is that rates of regret
and de-transition are low they will
often say that the rate of detransition
is one percent maybe two percent but it
turns out
that as with most transgender arguments
that talking point is not true a new
study on a sample of about 1 000
transitioners has found a detransition
rate of nearly 30 3-0 hat tip to Megan
McArdle from The Washington Post for
calling attention to this study it is
called the continuation of gender
affirming hormones among transgender
adolescents and adults study was
published in the journal of clinical
endocrinology and metabolism and it
found that the four-year trans hormone
continuation rate was just 70.2 percent
that's a far cry from the 98 99
statistic that the trans activists
promote
the rate of detransition was even higher
in women it was 35.6 and perhaps most
interesting of all it found that people
who started cross-sex hormones and the
transition process as minors had a
higher continuation rate as adults now
that fact is unsurprising in itself of
course people whose normal development
was impeded by cross-sex hormones people
for whom detransition would be much more
difficult are much less likely to
attempt it that part is not all that
interesting what is interesting is that
this higher rate helps to explain why
leftist activist groups and the big
Pharma companies that fund them seem so
hell-bent on peddling transgenderism to
younger and younger children the younger
the victim the more likely he is to
stick with the transition and the more
money goes into the coffers of the
people peddling the transgender Madness
I'm Michael Knowles this the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show we've got to
get to the most important story which is
that an 81 year old woman has made it to
the cover of these Sports Illustrated
Swimsuit Issue and frankly one she looks
very good especially for rage and two at
least it's a woman so that's I guess
that's a win in the culture I don't know
it's still not great though we will get
to that in just a moment first though
big Pharma is funding all this trans
stuff
all the trans stuff big Pharma is
funding a lot of the trans stuff and
this is not unique to the transgender
movement this is how politics often
works so story came out yesterday big
Pharma is funding organizations
activists organizations to push
transgenderism into hospitals the Human
Rights Campaign that's the leftist
organization that has the equal sign
they existed to redefine marriage and
say that the marriage it now also
includes
unions of Two Men and two women that was
the equal sign bumper sticker so you
basically avoided the entire debate over
what marriage is by simply framing the
debate as a matter of Rights who has the
right to get married and the HRC was
very effective and then the Supreme
Court redefined marriage so what was the
HRC going to do it pivoted it became a
pro-trans organization the HRC
is this leftist group that has something
called the health care equality index
and the healthcare Quality Index
measures quote Health Care Facilities
policies and practices related to the
equity and inclusion of their lgbtq plus
patients visitors and employees
now
who funds the health care equality index
I'll give you a hint
it's Pfizer it's Pfizer and other Pharma
companies HRC admits this you don't need
to put on your tinfoil hat and go
digging for it HRC says write on their
website that the healthcare Quality
Index quote was funded in part by grants
from Firma
phrma and Pfizer we all know Pfizer
's gigantic Pharma company that tried to
inject assault with poison for the last
three years it's a little bit of a
digression Pfizer very very powerful
pharmaceutical company and Pharma the
pharmaceutical researcher and
manufacturers of America is the trade
organization that represents the
nation's leading biopharmaceutical
research companies
so it's big Pharma broadly I don't even
mean just a single advisor it's it's the
whole industry is funding the HRC and
then HRC the activist group only
concerned with equality and freedom and
politics they go in and they effectively
act as the salesman for the big Pharma
drugs so they go in they say in the name
of equality and dignity you need to give
these gigantic pharmaceutical companies
a lot more money and then the hospitals
acquiesce it's not that this is all
about money
but money provides a lot of the
Firepower for this activism I think some
people think that the way that the CIA
operates or the way that intelligence
agencies operate is they go down to
their labs and they create these special
half robot humanoid-like creatures to go
out there and subvert different
political movements be they on the left
or on the right and the only time that's
ever happened is in the case of Pete
bootage who was literally assembled by
hand in Langley in a laboratory
somewhere below the Earth but for for
most cases no that's not how these
these groups operate whether we're
talking about the government like the
intelligence agencies or whether we're
talking about corporations like these
big trade organizations usually what
happens is when these groups want to
wield influence they will go and they
will find activists that already exist
people who are already inclined to
ideologically their way and what they'll
do is they'll just give them a little
push they'll give them money they'll
give them a little bit more access and a
little bit more influence I'm not saying
that HRC only exists for the money
clearly they like the money they're very
well-funded organization
but what happened here is the big Pharma
companies found these activist groups
they Juiced them with a ton of cash
those activist groups act as the shock
troops the people on the ground and then
big Pharma makes a lot of money
sometimes the way that this works is it
the pharmaceutical companies they'll
bypass that middle man sales person and
they'll go straight to the doctors and
then they'll pay the doctors they'll buy
off the doctors and then the doctors
will sell their drugs for them okay that
is a direct business model not a very uh
reputable or admirable business model
but it is a direct one now when you want
an effective and moral and just business
model you got to check out zip recruiter
right now go to ziprecruiter.com Knowles
when you want to hire the best people
you've got to check out ziprecruiter.com
Knowles hiring used to be really hard
you would post your job on multiple
sites hope the right people see it and
then wait for them to apply same goes
for finding a job you upload your resume
to every job posting site comb through
never-ending lists of jobs trying to
find the right position for you zip
recruiter is the best place to find the
right position or if you're an employer
the right person to head your team or to
join your team so right now go to
ziprecruiter.com
strive for free ZIP recruiters matching
technology excels at finding the most
qualified candidates for a wide range of
roles if you see a candidate you like
you can easily send that person a
personal invite so that he's more likely
to apply four out of five employers who
post on ZipRecruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day see for
yourself go to ziprecruiter.com
to try ZipRecruiter for free that is
ziprecruiter.com Knowles kwles
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire
in Oregon
the director of an Oregon pediatric
gender clinic so that the places that
are transiting the kids
we've just learned has received
thousands of dollars from a Pharma
company that coincidentally makes
puberty blockers wow what are the odds
Cara Connolly is the director of the
gender clinic at doranbecker Children's
Hospital in Portland
she's received at least 3 100 bucks from
Endo pharmaceuticals
according to data from the US
government's open payments transparency
program
now what does this mean you might say
about three thousand dollars that's not
that's not big money first of all three
grand is three grand okay and that's the
only payment that we know about from
this one particular pharmaceutical
company but let's say that it's just
three grand let's say the big farm is
just going around to individual doctors
and paying them three grand two grand
even I don't know a thousand bucks
what does that mean well according to
analysis from popublica propublica
they've discovered that quote doctors
who received payments linked to specific
drugs prescribed more of those drugs
this isn't rocket science
this isn't gender science okay it
doesn't have to be so complicated and
obscured by all this jargon turns out
that when you fund something you get
more of it when you incentivize
something you get more of that behavior
and this report from propublica found
out that quote on average across all
drugs providers who received payments
specifically tied to a drug prescribed
at 58 percent more than providers who
did not receive these payments there is
always a financial component here
again that does not mean that it's all
about the money but what this tells you
is if you want to stop certain depraved
behaviors like trancing the kids one
effective way to discourage translating
the kids is going to be to go to the
financial backing to cut off the source
that is providing all this fuel for the
movement so yes we got to go in we got
to ban this stuff obviously we got to
pass laws we got to make this illegal
for doctors who continue to do this we
need to throw them in prison we need to
wield the law as best we can but we can
also try to cut off the funding here we
can say pass a law okay big big Pharma
you're not allowed to fund the Human
Rights Campaign quote unquote Human
Rights Campaign what a ridiculous title
for a left-wing group we can go in there
we can say Hey Big Pharma companies
you're not allowed to bribe doctors
anymore sorry no more bribing doctors
sorry
and then what what are we going to see
58 decrease in the likelihood that the
doctors prescribe these drugs
you want to talk about quacks and
corruption in the medical industry this
is the most disturbing story I have seen
in a very very long time it seems like I
say that almost every single day this
one really is it it's from the Atlantic
very long story
it's called the abortion absolutist
Warren Hearn has been performing late
abortions for half a century after Roe
he is as busy with patients as ever
you look at this guy I'm not
exaggerating you get the impression that
you are seeing the face of the Devil
Himself this is an old guy who has
specialized for now upwards of half a
century
not just abortion can you imagine the
kind of Doctor Who says I'm gonna go get
my medical degree so that I can engage
in the very fulfilling gratifying task
of killing babies every single day
multiple babies every single day but
then furthermore the kind of abortionist
who says and I'm not just going to kill
those really little tiny babies where
it's kind of hard to make out their body
parts I'm going to kill late term babies
that's this guy
and he's still doing it and according to
the Atlantic he's busier than ever
what do we mean by late term we're
talking about
killing babies at 25 weeks gestation
we're talking about killing babies at 30
weeks gestation to put that into
perspective
this is what a baby looks like at 30
weeks gestation I just Googled 30-week
preemie baby
these are
in every single way in every physical
way babies who just look exactly like
babies that you see newborn really young
babies right when Mama goes to the
hospital gives birth comes out this this
is exactly what they look like they're a
little bit smaller so they're they're
being treated a little bit in the NICU
but in every single way are babies
their skin looks like their skin their
limbs look like their limbs their faces
look like their faces and this guy goes
in
and kills them multiple times a day for
50 years he has admitted in this article
to killing a girl just because she's a
girl because Mommy didn't want a girl
mommy wanted a boy so he goes in and
kills a baby who looks something like
this because she's a girl
and if she had been a boy she would have
lived but she's a girl so she's got to
be murdered
same thing he admits to killing a boy
for being a boy he admits this is an
amazing work of Journalism by Elaine
Godfrey he admits that he's killed
babies with a still beating heart after
he takes him out of his mother's womb
out of their mother's womb rather
he is admits that he's woken up in
Terror that he's been haunted by the
images of these babies and they're
Beating Heart Like The Edgar Allan Poe
Story the heart just beating wakes him
up
and he admits
that half or maybe even more than half
of the women who come to him seeking an
abortion
don't have any medical argument for
seeking that abortion
this is such a phenomenal work of
Journalism really probably deserves a
Pulitzer Prize because
one this author from the Atlantic has
gone out found the story that basically
no one had heard about
and she is knocked down so many of the
lies of the pro-abortion movement what
is the pro-abortion movement tell us the
baby's not a baby
here it is look at the bit you can see
that's a baby
what is the pro-abortion movement tell
us oh late term abortions don't happen
they're so exceedingly rare no it never
happens what are you talking about this
guy's busier than ever
oh people don't kill their babies
because of their sex they do
oh no the women who if you circulate
term abortion it's because your life is
threatened and you need to protect your
life no this guy admits half the time
more than half the time they just don't
want the baby so they're just going to
go to this
guy and kill the baby
the other reason this story is so
important
is because this is not just one guy this
is not just some extreme case this is
not just the Fringe of the industry
this is what all abortion is
the reason that we are particularly
horrified the reason why even the
majority of people vast majority of
people who would call themselves
pro-choice would still recoil in horror
and think that this should be banned
is because we look at the baby and
bypassing our reason we just have this
intense visceral emotional response to
images of vulnerable little babies that
we that we can immediately recognize to
be babies
foreign
but there's
no essential difference between this
baby
and the baby at 20 weeks for 15 weeks or
10 weeks or five weeks or the baby from
the moment of conception still baby
still an individual human life
being
snuffed out a person being murdered
with the ascent of the mother at the
hands of of Mengele Redux over here okay
that's what abortion is abortion stops a
beating heart
and you can't always see the beating
heart as clearly as that doctor has
sometimes outside the womb but it stops
a beating heart abortion is
undertaken for selfish reasons
it's not always as clear as oh I don't
really want a girl
but it's trial sacrifice at the altar of
false god
and ultimately at the altar of the self
undertaking for selfish reasons by the
people procuring them and undertaking
for selfish reasons by the doctors who
do it to make a lot of money
to say nothing of whatever other
psychological problems they've got this
guy in a in a just world
this guy
would be clearly violating the law and
if he continued to clearly violate the
law he would be executed by the state he
would be convicted by a jury of his
peers he would be he would receive
capital punishment this guy is one of if
not the single worst mass killer in
American history
Mass killer of the most vulnerable
innocent people brilliant journalism
really good stuff I don't know if the
author intended it to be such brilliant
journalism but it certainly is
we need to show what abortion looks like
I know that's a controversial tactic of
the pro-life movement it's
extraordinarily effective
we need to show what it looks like
there's a group that just went out they
got a boat and they decided to go
protest a party held by Planned
Parenthood here's how they did it they
got signs they got a bullhorn and they
got pictures of abortion really looks
like and here's how the pro-life group
interrupted this little nice Seaside
cocktail Soiree of people whose raise on
debt is to murder babies
the organization that does this to
little babies you guys are brainwashed
honestly open your eyes a three-year-old
could see a five-year-old could see that
this is wrong this is so utterly
shameful
[Music]
Ness
[Applause]
activism here right there's no subtlety
here there's no well we have different
views but we're going to sort of have a
reasonable conversation to meet in the
middle you know
that I'm all for that and I've had
conversations with pro-abortion people
and we've been very civil when we're
just presenting arguments
I'm all for civil disagreement I'm all
for gentlemanliness
but different issues call for different
kinds of tactics these people are
murdering little babies and so that
requires rhetoric that is a little bit
more pointed and direct and Urgent the
graphic photos are very effective
imagine if you were there at this party
what would you you would have two
options and only two options you could
either look at the photos or you could
turn away from the photos
and this is very effective for people
who say that they're pro-abortion if
you're working for Planned Parenthood
odds are you are a stone cold killer and
you're not going to be all that moved by
these sometimes you are I mean they're
they're great pro-life leaders who
worked for Planned Parenthood who worked
for the pro-abortion movement some of
whom helped lead the pro-abortion
movement they became huge pro-life
Advocates one of the founders of the
national abortion rights League Dr
Bernard Nathanson was one of those
people
but you've only got two options if
you're that person you're looking at
those pictures you can either look
steely-eyed cold in which case you are
clear to everyone around you a stone
cold psychopath
or you can look away
and the vast majority of people
who are not would be serial killers or
literal serial killers in some cases
they would look away they can't look at
it and the mere Act of looking away is
instructive that the act of looking away
from these photos is instructive to
the public broadly why can't the
abortion Advocates stand by their belief
stand on their principles look what
they're doing Square in the face what
does that mean about what they're doing
and it's instructive to the pro-abortion
people themselves
to the people who look away
we we can learn things about ourselves
from our own behavior
and very often it's easier to change our
minds than to change our behavior and if
you have that gut visceral reaction to
whoa I can't look at this this is evil
I'm looking away huh I guess I've
learned something about myself maybe
I've learned something about what the
reality of this is do not go soft
there's a
an instinct among conservatives
sometimes especially when we're winning
to back off a little bit don't back off
this issue we got to talk about it when
you want to talk to your friends you've
got to check out pure talk right now go
to puretalk.com Knowles do you remember
the last time you got a free phone you
started out feeling great and then came
the Hefty activation fees the four line
requirements and of course that binding
contract Pure Talk is giving you a free
5G Samsung Galaxy phone without the
feeling that you've been duped when you
switch to Pure talks unlimited talk and
text data plan that comes with a mobile
hotspot you will get a 5G Samsung Galaxy
for free that's right unlimited
everything at a fraction of the price at
Verizon ATT T-Mobile here's another
thing you'll be on America's Most
Dependable 5G Network
not just a similar Network they'd be on
the same one how do I know I'm a
customer make the switch to Pure Talk
the cell phone Wireless company that I
am proud to stand behind because they
have a fabulous service and they are
proud to stand behind our mission at the
daily wire there are us-based customer
service team which frankly is reason
enough to switch can help you switch in
as little as 10 minutes you can even
keep your own phone number go to
puretalk.com Knowles for your free
Samsung Galaxy when you sign up for
unlimited talk text and unlimited data
that is puretalk.com
Wireless for Americans by Americans the
libs
Thrive by obscuring reality
that's what they do okay we'll get into
that in one second first though you can
never start thinking about Father's Day
gifts too early that's what I tell my
wife most days of the year I say you
gotta start thinking about Father's Day
okay don't let that slip You by very
important
a gift of Jeremy's razors is Dual
Purpose not only are you helping your
dad look his best each day you're also
kicking woke out of his bathroom
there is no other razor that can do that
shaving is not just about grooming
it's about embracing masculinity and
feeling like a real man
all right take it from me save 30 off on
Jeremy's razors
select bundles and razor starter sets as
part of our Father's Day Sale go to
jeremy'sraisers.com today help Dad kick
woke out of his bathroom
the libs Thrive by obscuring reality
new slogan just dropped
new jargon politically correct phrase
just dropped
you remember diversity and inclusion I
mentioned this at the end of the show
yesterday diversity and inclusion that's
out that's canceled
that is passe old man get with the new
hip lingo the new hip lingo is diversity
and
belonging
very different but this is what I'm told
by the New York Times why some companies
are saying diversity and belonging
instead of diversity and inclusion
before I read this article I just saw
the headline
I said I know exactly why they've done
that
because diversity and inclusion is a an
Anodyne sounding euphemism
for
a hideous
activity and the Hideous activity is the
leftist campaign to incite race hate
against white people and sexual
absurdity among everybody that's all it
means
diversity and equity and inclusion all
those policies mean in practice is
discriminate against white people and
promote sexual disorder and chaos and
Madness
and tell dudes that they're chicks and
chicks that they're dudes and people
that they can be in troubles with to
women four guys and a billy goat
how is that a throuple I don't know it
identifies as three
that's all Dei is
and so why are they changing the the
euphemism
because they are on what Stephen Pinker
and Harvard calls the euphemism
treadmill Stephen pinker's a liberal guy
but he observed this fact about language
and I talk about in my book speechless
controlling words controlling Minds
which is available wherever you want to
hello where's my bell okay finally
the euphemism treadmill
observes that political activists have
to change euphemisms regularly because
the purpose of political euphemisms
especially when we're talking about
something like political correctness is
not to soften harsh truths not to use
just a slightly more polite phrase but
to lie to deceive people
if you say that an illegal alien is an
undocumented American you're not just
softening the truth a little bit you're
lying you're telling the opposite of
what whatever the illegal alien is he's
not an American and so if you call him
an undocumented American you're just
telling a lie
but what happens is that when you lie
through the use of this language
ultimately people begin to remember and
to recognize the odious underlying
reality of the thing that you're lying
about
and so the odious underlying reality of
that thing starts to color the euphemism
even if it's the floweriest nicest
sounding euphemism ever so the euphemism
takes on this stench the euphemism takes
on this this nasty kind of connotation
and so the radicals if they want to keep
up the racket they've got to change the
euphemism so I knew that instantly
when I saw that headline I said okay
maybe I'm being prejudicial maybe I'm
rushing to judgment and then I read the
article and that's exactly what it is
the libs are realizing that people have
turned against Dei and so instead of
saying all right we're going to abandon
this very unpopular and unjust and
hideous sort of political campaign they
say no I'm not going to do that I know
what we're going to do I know we're not
going to change any of the underlying
reality of what we're doing we're just
going to change the slogan to diversity
and belonging instead now the thing is
it will work for some time political
correctness which we now call wokeness
has worked pretty well as a political
campaign so we'll do people from some
time but the the odious underlying
reality of that campaign is going to
Dawn on people again then they're going
to change the words again speaking of
Politically Incorrect terms there is a
member of parliament in the motherland
British MP
who is attacking a conservative Tory MP
for referring to the ideology and the
intellectual movement of cultural
Marxism
now speaking of that book I told you
about earlier
speechless controlling words controlling
Minds that's my number one best-selling
book National bestseller you can get
there thank you uh
for the first part of that book in
particular I talk about this
intellectual
movement that dominated uh leftist
politics in the 20th century well
according to this left-wing MP
quote cultural Marxism is an
anti-semitic conspiracy theory supported
by neo-nazis in groups like The BMP
disturbing to see another Tori MP
spreading it after Sue Ella Braverman
did the same in 2019. we can't let
far-right language be normalized in
politics
I don't blame cultural Marxism or
neo-marxism or 20th century Marxism all
of which are synonymous for everything
in fact I think that that intellectual
movement is blamed for more than it
should be blamed for and I think the
reason it's blamed for more than it
should be blamed for is because a lot of
conservatives don't realize that
liberalism is bad too but not every
terrible thing in the world owes to
Marxism actually liberalism the modern
kind of liberalism the classical kind of
liberalism liberalism broadly is also
very bad and and is responsible for a
lot of ills so sometimes I think
conservatives project some of the ills
of liberalism onto other intellectual
movements including cultural Marxism
but
that doesn't mean that cultural Marxism
doesn't exist
it's a very well-known intellectual
movement described as such as a cultural
kind of Marxism by the very prominent
left-wing intellectuals at the very
prominent institutions which they taught
and operated
for for
much of the 20th century if you look
back on Wikipedia just a few years ago
type in cultural Marxism it'll say
cultural Marxism was part of the Marxist
tradition in the west that really came
to the fore in the 20th century and it
was promoted by thinkers such as uh
Herbert Marcus Theodore adorno the
Frankfurt School uh it actually predates
the Frankfurt School a little bit uh
with Italian thinkers like Antonio
gromshi or lukash over in Hungary or a
number of other people
and these these guys had positions of
prominence they taught at very prominent
American universities including Columbia
University they worked with the
government Herbert Marcus have worked
with the OSS which was the precursor to
the CIA Herbert marcusa then went on to
become the father of the new left again
I didn't give in that title it was the
leftists who gave him that title he
remains extraordinarily influential
they're fairly interesting thinkers
they're they're wrong ultimately they're
wrong about everything they're wrong in
the meantime about a lot of things but
they have lots of interesting
observations I've read them
extensively and I in fact I wrote a book
about these guys
to say that that doesn't exist
is simply ignorant
but this story mp1 doesn't know anything
about anything so she
ironically though
she would accuse us of ignorance or dog
whistling or whatever she has never read
these people these people whose
intellectual work has laid the
groundwork for many of her views and
activities even unbeknownst to her
but furthermore what she's engaging in
is
ironically or maybe not a product of
cultural Marxism a product of of
attaining cultural hegemony a war of
position rather than a war of movement
to use the language of Antonio ramshi
whereby the libs take over the culture
and you barely even notice that they've
done it and then what happens once
they've attained that cultural hegemony
because they ultimately turn away from
objective truth in reality they deny the
reality of what they've done it's really
no different from Stalin erasing people
that he liquidated out of his
photographs
people that he purged
just oop no that person was never there
because if you believe that history is
fundamentally a matter not of God's
Providence and not of ideas coming to
their logical conclusions and not of
reason at least because it marxists to
some degree do believe that history is
is a consequence of ideas coming to
their logical conclusions but it's
divorce from reason it's divorced from
objective truth it's certainly a divorce
from God
if you believe that that it's really
just fundamentally about the will then
you can go in and say oh yeah that
prominent intellectual movement yeah
that's an anti-semitic conspiracy theory
it's so Brazen it it is almost as Brazen
as saying
50 years from now oh you you keep
mentioning Hillary Clinton who's Hillary
Hillary Clinton never existed what are
you talking about that's a tin foil hat
racist phobic anti-semitic conspiracy
theory
you I said well look at all the evidence
and look at all the we have all the
video footage and we have all of the
Testament of the people who are you
talking about
that never happened two plus two equals
five what are you talking about speaking
of willful ignorance
conservatives are still focusing some of
their Firepower on Hunter Biden Nancy
mace
who is a liberal Republican but she's
kind of feisty and fiery and
occasionally she's on the right side of
an issue Nancy mace is furious that the
Democrats and the doj are not taking the
case against Hunter Biden more seriously
here we have a doj and FBI who are who
are indicting Trump on misdemeanors and
then will not investigate Biden for
betraying his country and I have to tell
you absolutely no one can accuse me of
being hyper partisan or being in the
tank for Donald Trump but good Lord the
amount of evidence in this case is
ridiculous they weren't hiring Hunter
Biden for his brains they weren't hiring
certainly Hunter Biden for his Braun
they were hiring him to pay for access
to the White House and we see this
pattern repeat itself over and over and
over again
obviously that's true and you can hear
Nancy Mason's exasperation the evidence
that we have against Hunter Biden is
ridiculous
that's the problem
that's one of the big problems here
it is ridiculous it's insane if we only
had a small amount of evidence against
Hunter Biden that would be one thing it
would actually be easier I would feel
better about our prospects of
Prosecuting this guy
but because the evidence is so
overwhelming because his crimes were so
cartoonishly villainous at every level
the white collar crimes the the payoffs
the bribery the deception the fraud down
to the street level grabs this guy's
smoking crack getting beaten up by the
skid row he's got a different hooker it
seems every hour of the day he's filming
all of his activities with all of these
people singing to camera I am committing
crimes here is all the evidence of my
crimes then he leaves the laptop with
all the evidence at a repair shop and
the doj does nothing about it that's the
problem
it's so brazen
it shows you the the
pervasiveness and the depth of the
corruption of our government
yeah it's totally ridiculous and what
are you going to do about it what are
any of us going to do about it
even if they do indict they got what are
they going to do they're going to indict
them they're going to try him on some
lesser charges then they're going to
give him like five minutes probation
they just go right back to selling his
stupid Doodles for half a million dollar
a pop which is the same racket that he's
been playing the whole time
the whole time that he's been an adult
that his father's been in politics
what's he been doing he's been selling
influence ultimately selling out the
American government to the highest
better he's just gonna keep doing that
yeah it's ridiculous it's not just
Hunter Biden's ridiculous it's the whole
system
the system is not going to destroy one
of its own
knock it's even if the system made a
little bit of an example out of Hunter
Biden that corruption is going to
continue on occasionally the libs will
admit when they are in the wrong
and I want to give them credit for it
they don't deserve full credit for it
but they deserve a little bit of credit
for it Jake Tapper the other day after
the Durham report comes out the Durham
report which shows there was no basis
for spying on Trump's campaign there was
no basis for the Russia hoax it was
completely cooked up by the Clinton
campaign the CIA director knew that it
was cooked up by the Clinton campaign
not only the CIA director but the head
of the FBI the vice president the
president himself Barack Obama they all
knew it was a dirty trick campaign stunt
nonsense by Hillary and they proceeded
with a straight face to try to destroy
Trump anyway this all it was spelled out
clear as day in the Durham report Jake
Tapper of CNN admits huh this is pretty
damning
regardless the report is now here it has
dropped and it might not have produced
everything of what some Republicans
hoped for it is regardless devastating
to the FBI and to a degree it does
exonerate Donald Trump
so Jake Tapper goes even further than
you might have expected not only does he
admit okay this is really bad for the
FBI damning actually not just a little
bit damning
but further
and Jake Tapper can't go the whole way
so but he has to
throw a caveat or two in there but
nevertheless he says
it exonerates Trump
yeah and that's great we should remember
that and the next time the libs try to
Pedal all this the walls are closed
again it's Mueller time he's a Russian
Putin stooge or whatever you can say hey
even Jake Tapper who's a live who
started at his career as a Democrat
political operative who has remained a
Democrat political operative albeit one
who calls himself a newsman on TV but
he's a little bit more fair than the
other guys
he comes out and he says
yeah okay this exonerates Trump and the
lips will sometimes do that
once it no longer matters the limbs will
sometimes occasionally very often
they'll keep up the LIE deny till you
die but but sometimes they will admit
that years later the Russia hoax began
in 2016. it is now the year of Our Lord
2023 and finally seven years later the
libs will say
yeah okay I guess we kind of made it all
up oopsie
that's old news now moving on moving on
my favorite comment yesterday
is from Petro M and we'll get to that in
one second first I got to tell you why I
feel so good why I look so fresh why I'm
just so cozy at night that would be of
course
because of cozy Earth right now go to
cozyearth.com promo code Knowles
everyone deserves the best of everything
including the best night's sleep you
know me
I am a simple man easily Satisfied by
the very best when it comes to Sheets
that's cozy Earth our friends at cozy
Earth are here to give you super soft
luxurious designer preferred betting
whether you are looking to treat
yourself or someone you love cozy or
Earth has a gift guide that can help you
start looking for that perfect gift cozy
Earth's luxury bedding and loungewear
transforms lives by offering the world's
softest most luxurious and responsibly
sourced betting do you ever wonder what
it's like to be lying there on my bed in
my Boudoir get that out of your mind I'm
a married man but you can have a similar
experience on your own bed with cozy
Earth their products are temperature
regulating and moisture wicking fabric
it will keep you comfy right now they're
extending their Mother's Day sale for a
limited time their site's offering a
discount and our listeners will still be
getting up to 35 off with promo code
Knolls Canada w-les at checkout right
now head on over promo code Knowles
k-n-o-w-l-e-s you can save up to 35 off
your order at cozyearth.com
okay
wonderful comment yesterday from Petro M
who says
it's a quote from Miller Lite
hey Bud Light
hold my beer
do you get it I love a good one-liner
you know a good little Henny Youngman
all right like for instance take my wife
please okay we've got to get to the
really important stories now
now would be the 81 year old woman
gracing the cover of Sports Illustrated
this has created some controversy
and if I gotta weigh in on on just
aesthetically speaking how the cover
looks
Martha Stewart looks great
certainly for an 81 year old woman
certainly for a 71 year old woman
certainly for a 61 year old woman
she frankly looks great for like a 51
year old woman
maybe even a woman in her 40s it is
shocking how good Martha Stewart looks I
don't only say this because Martha
Stewart is a great
basically wholesome traditional cultural
figure by the way it's not like she's
wearing a bikini or something in this
it's a pretty tasteful
Sports Illustrated cover
but we all suspect something that's kind
of wrong with this
so it just feels wrong to have an 81
year old on your swimsuit cover right
but people are having trouble putting
their finger on exactly what's wrong
about it for one she's she's a woman
that's more than can be said of sports
illustrated's cover in in recent years
there's there is a transsexual a trans
identifying man in uh this this issue as
well
now part of why Sports Illustrated does
this is be a Sports Illustrated Swimsuit
Issue is an anachronism it used to be
really kind of fun in titillating back
in the 90s even the 2000s back before
the ubiquity of Hardcore internet
pornography back when people would go
down to the newsstand back when those
still existed and they'd buy the
magazine we're going to see some pretty
women wearing not a lot of clothing but
now you go on the internet whatever the
most depraved disordered desire you can
possibly imagine is you can multiply it
by 300 and you can find it the click of
a of a button so Sports Illustrated in
order to stay relevant to stay in the
news
it has to create controversy and one way
to create controversy is to pretend that
dudes are chicks which is obviously
completely disgusting but at least gets
them in the news and then a better way
for them to create controversy is to put
an 81 year old woman on the cover so
okay mission accomplished they did that
but why is it wrong why is it wrong
that even this very good-looking woman
that 81 years old is Undercover I go
back to a line from
Saint Gregory the Great which has been
popularized in recent years by Saint
Jose Maria scriva which is that
it is not good to look at what it is not
illicit to desire
and I'm not going to use this line in
its precision
I just mean it as a way to sort of get
at why people feel like it's a little
bit wrong they have an 81 year old woman
wearing a swimsuit on the cover of this
magazine
we think it's wrong because we know it's
not we should we should not be
sexually Desiring an 81 year old woman
even an 81 year old woman who's a
beloved cultural figure who looks very
very good especially for age it's just
that's not right
it makes sense to sexually desire
when you're a young man and you're
single and you're looking at a date and
get married it makes sense to desire
the women around your age
and then to follow that desire by asking
the girl out to get a drink or to get
dinner and then to follow that desire by
dating for a period of time and then to
follow that desire by getting married
and to follow that desire by doing that
thing that Mary Pebbles do and then to
follow that desire by creating children
as a result of your your physical
expression of that Bond of love that
love which becomes so real that it
actually becomes expressed in a new
person and to allow that love to deepen
and to desire in a way that changes and
deepens and grows over time your spouse
until both of you are 81 and you're
sitting on a porch somewhere sipping
iced tea looking at all your kids and
grandkids that makes sense
but it's kind of weird for a young man
who are supposedly the people who are
buying the Sports Illustrated swimsuit
issue
to be ogling an 81 year old a woman who
could be their grandmother that's wrong
and even if Martha Stewart I don't know
if she's had any work done give Martha
the benefit of the dad but let's assume
like most celebrities she said like
maybe just a little bit of work here and
there she's got personal trainers at
least in good diet and let's assume that
there's some airbrushing going on in
Photoshop to kind of make the picture
look a little bit better
it's
it's wrong to feel that desire even if
you say the whole concept of the
swimsuit issue is a little bit wrong
because it's inciting lust or something
which again that's a whole separate
argument
but whatever it is
it's not meant
for 81 year olds that's just not
appropriate
and
radicals want to distill all of life
down to three bullet points on a napkin
that they can call their political
Manifesto but life is more complex than
that
and one way to approach these kinds of
thoughts is
with moderation and with prudence and
with practical wisdom and with
recognizing that things are meant to be
in their proper place when a man behaves
like a woman that's improper that's
womanish
when a woman behaves like a woman that's
proper that's womanly they're both
behaving like women why can't they do
that well because one is not proper to
their nature and one is proper to their
nature
and the nature of the Sports Illustrated
swimsuit issue is that it is not proper
for an 81 year old woman to be on the
cover no matter how good she looks
speaking of women of a certain age
a bit older than Martha Stewart
Cleopatra not doing very well in the
ratings we've talked about Cleopatra
which is the Netflix documentary about
a famously white woman
who spoke Greek who is an ancient ruler
around the Mediterranean who's now being
portrayed by a black woman
in a way that is a little bit absurd
especially if we're talking about it in
a historical product here
uh Well turns out viewers agree with my
take that this is absurd the docudrama
has a two percent audience score
and not only that because you might say
well maybe it was political activists
who bombarded the the audience score on
Rotten Tomatoes it's only got 11 critics
too this thing is getting absolutely
panned
one audience member is saying this is
hopelessly inaccurate and a complete
failure to understand Egyptian culture
and history no depth or atmosphere of
the time just a poor attempt to
americanize Egyptian history by changing
it to suit American culture okay that's
what one of the viewers says one of the
critics says it's too soapy for serious
history fans and not enough soap for
viewers who like juicy historical dramas
it's just it's just not
proper
it's I don't I don't know who this
actress is maybe she's a good actress
but it's not her role she's miscast and
even a very very good actor in the wrong
role
is not going to give you a great
performance and the work of art is going
to fail
falsehood
produces bad art
good art is truthful
what falsehood produces is absurdity
things out of whack and absurdity and
things being out of whack and
incongruity that can make funny comedy
that's that is one of the most prominent
constituent parts of funny comedy but it
doesn't make beautiful art it doesn't
make documentaries really people can
people can suss that out when a modern
artist goes around and points to a
urinal and says that's art isn't it so
beautiful
everyone knows it's not beautiful it's
not because the urinal is a bad thing
the urinal has a proper place it's
called the bathroom it's called the
men's room or I guess as we move into
our Brave New World probably the women's
room too
but we know but we know that that's
absurd we would laugh at that and
certainly in an art gallery that would
be absurd things need to be in their
proper place and the proper place for my
iPad is in front of me on this table
right now we are heading into the member
block it is well Wednesday my producer
the Intrepid Ben Davies is sitting here
uh he has got
a very important tick tock
to teach us all about systemic racism so
we will get to that we will be in the
chat head on over to dailywire.com
Knowles at checkout get two months free
on all annual plans
[Music]